[Musik]
auch heute wollen wir uns ansehen welche
militärischen aspekte denn bei der mega
offensive der russischen armee die
bereits seit zwei wochen im osten der
ukraine vonstatten geht denn wichtig
sind und auch heute wollen wir uns mal
neue aspekte ansehen nämlich wir wollen
uns ansehen wie wichtig schwere waffen
dort sind schwere waffen über die auch
in deutschland immer wieder debattiert
wird über die der bundestag an sich ein
jahr gegeben hat ein ja aber denn wir
schicken weiterhin kaum schwere waffen
in die ukraine und vielleicht erinnern
wir uns noch mal vor kiew wie dort die
kämpfe vonstatten gegangen sind wir
erinnern uns dass dort diese russischen
konvois hinein kamen und dass dort die
ukrainische soldaten links und rechts
der straße gewartet haben hier im norden
des landes und quasi mit ihren schulter
gestützten raketen auch aus deutschland
mit der panzerfaust 3 mit der jeweiligen
aus russland und so weiter mit der
endlos aus den usa mit der ende aus
großbritannien dort diesen konvois
aufgebaut haben und die soldaten standen
sich quasi direkt gegenüber im osten der
ukraine wieso mir mal ein bisschen rein
im osten der ukraine ist es völlig
anders hier haben wir in den regionen
kaki flug ans netz geben diese
grossoffensive die dort vonstatten geht
und man muss sagen das ist immer mehr
ein traditioneller krieg ein krieg mit
schweren waffen ein krieg in dem sich
die soldaten eben nicht mehr wie früher
in die augen sehen und direkt
voneinander stehen sondern über viele
kilometer entfernung aufeinander
schießen also das ganze koordiniert so
zu sagen und sich kaum noch gegenseitig
treffen das heißt die meisten soldaten
werden hier getötet bevor auch nur einer
den anderen gesehen hat und wie das
genau passiert das schauen wir uns immer
an zuerst schauen wir uns so sicher
aufnahmen an das ist eine video einer
russischen überwachungsdrohne vom typ
ordnern 10 und hier wollen wir nochmal
uns angucken wie drohnen und schwere
waffen nämlich artillerie und
raketensystemen hier zusammen arbeiten
zu sehen ist hier ein ukrainischer lkw
hier im oben im bild und da unten ein
artilleriegeschütz das heißt auch dass
eben eine wichtige waffe ein lkw die
hier gerade steht und ein
artilleriegeschütz 1 1 ort bringt die
russische drohne guckt sich das genau
erzählt ihnen an überträgt die daten an
die eigene artillerie nämlich den
genauen gps-daten also die koordinaten
und dann gibt es diesen angriff und wir
sehen uns hier in dem moment wie dort
der ukrainische laster mit der
artillerie dahinter getroffen wird von
verschiedenen geschossen und dann
natürlich nicht mehr einsatzbereit ist
ob wir menschen dabei gestorben sind
können wir nicht sagen
sicher ist dass dieser lkw eben nicht
mehr weiterfahren kann und diese woche
sozusagen nicht mehr ans ziel geliefert
werden kann das machen die russen auf
der einen seite sehen hier noch mal
wirklich den brennenden lkw am ende und
was machen auch die ukraine und auch die
ukraine nutzen genau diese koordination
also von drohnen in der luft die sich
einen überblick verschaffen und vom
artillerie am boden die dann daraufhin
reagiert hier das einmal kurz markieren
sehen wir wie ein russischer
schützenpanzer vom typ b mp2 sich einem
eroberten haus und zwar im kultur
gebäude in der region donetsk eroberten
stadt nähert das etwa 30 kilometer
nördlich von mario pohl er fährt dort
rein und will sich dort verstecken was
er nicht weiß er wird dabei beobachtet
das heißt die ukrainische drohne guckt
sich genau an wo fährt er gerade lang wo
bewegt er sich und wir sehen gleich
nochmal ein überblick überblick der
ganzen situation die keiner beobachten
also ganz genau wo er sich versteckt und
die drohne gibt diese daten live weiter
an die artillerie das ist das ganze ein
bisschen weiter weg hier sehen wir die
stadt im überblick das heißt so weit ist
die ukrainische drohen auch entfernt das
sind vielleicht fünf kilometer aber sie
kann im run zoomen kann genau sehen wo
das ist das macht sie jetzt auch die
erzieher hinein und wieso und darf noch
einmal an wir haben uns an das gebäude
eben das ist das gebäude hier direkt
neben einer kirche und neben einer
schule wo wahrscheinlich niemand mehr
drin ist die meisten steht ist
menschenleer in den bussen einrücken und
dann passiert was wir uns von denken
können nämlich ein ukrainisches geschoss
strick dir schlägt hier ganz genau in
diesem haus einschlägt also genau dort
ein wo der russische schützenpanzer sich
versteckt und höchstwahrscheinlich gab
es denn hier auch verluste unter den
russischen truppen diese koordinierung
zwischen drohnen und artillerie ist
extrem wichtig und wir schauen uns noch
einmal an was für waffen denn das
überhaupt sind und warum auch der
bundestag dann kommen sie zurück zum
anfang hier eigentlich so wichtig ist
und sich hier entscheiden müsste hier
sehen wir russische selbstfahrer fetten
vom typ mister es zu heißen die und die
fahnen in der region aktiv auf dutzende
von den russland hat hunderte davon dass
deutsche bonbon dazu wäre die
panzerhaubitze 2000 die wild deutschland
aber weiter nicht liefern obwohl die
bundeswehr über 100 davon in eigenen
diensten deutschland sagt wir bilden aus
wir geben munition aber wir geben wir
bilden nur aus auf den 55
panzerhaubitzen 2000 die niederlande
liefern während russland wir sehen es
hier hunderte davon im einsatz hat und
deshalb auch im osten der ukraine
aktuell die oberhand hat weil es eben so
wichtig es dass dort schwere waffen zum
einsatz kommen
[Musik]